6 15 now a first of its kind app is
launching here in las vegas to change
how fans enjoy live sports really
interesting alex
love seats it is an app it lets fans buy
and sell tickets while you're
at the game the app launches next month
for the las vegas aviators when they
start play out at the ballpark in
summerlin
so for example say it's the fifth inning
and you want to move closer to the field
you can look and see if there's an
available seat there's a flat fee on the
sales and pricing changes
in real time as the game goes on
the big benefit is i mean if you don't
like your seats and you want to move you
want
you want to feel more like a vip or you
want to be behind the first base dugout
or third base dugout
it's really about all about maximizing
fan experience so giving the fans
everything they want being able to kind
of sit where they want
even though they maybe don't have the
best seats when the game starts they are
able to upgrade during the game
so you can also use the app when you
leave a game and sell the seat you're
leaving behind
or if you want to move and sit closer
with your friends in a different section
same deal love seats is also in talks
with the golden knights and a few other
teams across the country so that way
say you're at a game and as you know
you're at a golden knights game or at an
aviator's game you're in the seventh
inning
there's a bunch of seats up front you
want to get a little closer to the
action you don't have to go through the
awkward process native finding the seat
settling in and then all of a sudden the
usher comes up and says hey
you're out of here you don't know in
this scene you can be like yes i do look
at my phone
well back in the day you probably could
have gotten away with stuff like that
but at the knights games they're
the seats that are unavailable i mean
they're they've got stuff over them you
can't even well
synonymous now and i'm not sure how uh
las vegas ballpark is planning on doing
that
i'm guessing they're going to have
limited capacity as well so
it's a way from as far from my point of
view it's a way for the teams to
monetize what people have been sneaking
around doing for you
i mean a way to make more money maybe
alex who'd a thunk
i know it uh no it's a good idea i mean
a lot of us just kind of have done that
anyway yeah
so now do you have to pay for the
upgrade like if you want to move down
three sections that's what the app is
all about is putting some money down to
legally and officially move forward so
that they won't kick you out well
i hope it's prorated i hope it's like
hey i'm only paying for the last four
years i'm sure
that's what i said yeah they said the
prices change in real time
right okay good